hello everybody my name is Federico and
romani I'm an engineering manager here
at Google I work in Google Kyle and
specifically in kubernetes I just
finished my talk which was about an
introduction to CBI machinery
I am the co-chair of the C API machinery
which is a super central part of
kubernetes clusters as you know all your
requests anything that we want to do
with the cluster is going to come
through our software what are the parts
of qualities that we own and also what
are the parts of quality that we don't
all some people think that because we
are called API machinery we own all the
qualities api's which is not the right
thing so and I think was a good talk to
give an overview of what we on the other
part of the talk was about how you can
get in or if we want to open
community and specifically in corn
Eddie's okay machinery has this fame of
being a super hard part of the
kubernetes cluster which is true we have
a big responsibility but it's not
impossible so I would love to see some
of you showing up in our operations
meetings so can show up learn listen
contribute to help us I would also like
to invite all of you to come to the
Google book is here very good thank you
very much
[Music]
[Music]